ok so before you start let's take a look
at how would you define some extent and
we've probably heard of genomics
transcriptomics and genomics and
proteomics etc there's we need to touch
the box data so on would you define what
is all excited what is common between
common types of data another question
that i would like to consider is if you
can think of any example of big data and
health care if you're thinking
electronic medical records or divisive
sending signals and cannot become large
data source and what would other
examples would you have a big data in
healthcare so the title of the talk
today is personalized medicine how would
you improve health care and the deep
cost of this personalized approach
through many different styles sectors
across research and discovery education
analysis of the data industry final
industry health care industry obsession
so how we can improve the delivery of
and how can we reduce the cost
enforcement business so again came for a
moment what is first my pleasure how's
that different from non for smart
lighting or evidence-based medicine have
you thought of any examples as
personalized medicine for many reasons
for non-personal medicine and again if
you think about this personalized
medicine of course is an overused term
and somewhat of a cliche and we also
tend to call a decision medicine the
stratified medicine there is terminology
for this presentation was clicking
personalized medicine I'm aiming with
the younger so what is the problem the
problem is that healthcare non-personal
an active site a lot of times I have a
precise measurements there's only a few
options there's a lot of look alike
diagnostics right so you see a symptom
and looks like something elephant we
don't America's a lot
analogies and then trying to treatment
so let's try this treatment in for a
couple of weeks doesn't work you know
what I think Alton of course as you know
a good example is the resistance to
antibiotics that is developing because
of the Australian to treatment and
bottom lines leading to that outcomes
especially we can you see this for 1.1
check the data right to 1.7 and million
user to the new cases of cancer will be
diagnosed in the US in this year having
about 600,000 people will die from
cancer in the US alone and there what's
surprising is that about forty percent
of the total population will experience
will be diagnosed with cancer cell phone
during in lifetimes them now for you
presenters close to a hat which is a lot
of people just to drive this point home
cleaning your cases in one death per
minutes we've been doing this for a few
minutes you can think about how many
people have been diagnosed or that
center during this time so the two main
components are personalized money for
diagnostic and a trance or Heinrich
diagnose a conditioning amount original
with that way and how do you then treat
it a more personal consumption so on the
demographics are available we see that
about 40 million cancer patients die
chair and result of misdiagnosis or
delayed items this is an interesting
statistic and coffee do you feel at and
diagnostics please we're growing so
why's it so complicated so it's
complicated because cancer is so complex
so what we call cancer it is actually
many different amigas with many
different types and subtypes and you can
see here the chart as you can find
online and call our country and and you
can see how many different types and
subtypes and subtypes of subtypes of
breast cancer we see on this chart so
so what is the need for molecular
positions kids want to identify
precisely that the type of the cancer
you really need to know some of the
genetic difference and so you can see
the two different pictures of different
cancers and you can see how the visual
picture is different but of course also
the genetic component of why why those
morphological differences occur so
really it's a dis regulation of gene
expression that leads to cancer native
science cancer subtype for a second you
think about the value of diagnostic so
diagnostics and started Kenneth in
cancer but it was a much broader topic
and only about two percent of World War
II or worldwide healthcare spending is
used on Diagnostics but the benefits of
about family descended conditions anthem
exam the decision-making like news much
I Diagnostics as a critical component of
health care you can see replies to many
different conditions including
cardiovascular personalized medicine can
check point of care infectious diseases
we also have you on the side eleni that
suffered cancer early on actually at the
age of 25 and because she had official
diagnostic and a team that note knew how
to utilize those that you're sick she is
long healthy continued so what about the
cost of dying lost you like that a
diagonal to my core data since 2014 has
been widely they were born and the cost
is to generate data has been below a
thousand dollars which is approximately
the cost of generating the CT scan data
and now we are even below that 262 6460
cost of entrance and it will ruin just
recently announced intuition that will
provide sequencing data for buy for less
than a hundred
click here right to the second major
component of health care of course
therapeutics and here we have which that
about 350 billion which wasted on
prescription truck in 2001 okay let's
return to our cancer kings and think
here's an example of 150,000 three-year
drug called optima and immunotherapy
therapy for long teens and can't give
you know therapy of course implies more
personalized approach but here we also
have this other statistic that on
average immediate improvements which of
Iowa works only one drug approved by the
US Food and Drug Administration for
treating solid cancers over the last
decade and that the improvement is only
2.1 months to really extend your life by
12 to watch and that's not a big
improvement and also send me back the
kind of cancer drugs had those
applications up now before we do want to
let's think about it for a few minutes
what are some reasons for these drugs
being effective is it to design some to
delivery it's a better patient adherence
so many different factors here's chords
what are some of the reasons for cancer
drug costs you know why does it cost
much to develop this lighting the
customers to bring it to market to get
it approved and also one of the reasons
for cancer care beings of coffee right
schisandra therapeutics at Cancer Care
and general all right so um here's a
good example of a real world scenario
where you have similar clinical
conditions but they differ in their
molecular future so for example to have
in chemistry old fish and tests for
patients and the patient kept identified
as a virtue that can compulsion and
let's prescribe treatment testing and
what we learn to those of course the
whole stations actually do not respond
to reflect on a lot why well because
using the Pam 50 molecular test which is
a test that we can gain expression gene
expression of about 50 jeans or yeah
food key genes called empathy will be
identified as the luminal subtype and
those patients do not respond to
treatment so think about that think
about the changing economics of
delivering this kind of care so we have
this lung cancer subgroup is called
alk-positive non squamous non-small cell
lung cancer NSCLC these patients have
been responding to new treatment that
coming to market and they respond well
so we can see you got a proportion of
them actually a response will want to
treatment but the problem is that
there's only 13 thousand of those people
as 14 million people diagnosis one
there's less than one percent so think
about that market development the
research the marketing efforts for
delivery efforts to identify the right
patients and to deliver them as a kind
of care but in my view mode if we had
great diagnostics and great their pubes
what we would see of course is that the
number of different tests will help the
clinicians match the patient with the
right treatment you know the risk and
mass into clinical trials if the
clinical trials over
all right now look at let's look at the
province of delivery how to work a
patient comes in to the doctor and
collision will they get referred to the
clinical lab and clinical lab has to be
able to generate the right type of data
take the rate of examples generate the
regional Gail perform analysis of data
and an interpreting right to the
clinician after the patient comes back
has to be interpreting that data
correctly so that's where we see the
data component right if you think of the
type of data that we're dealing with
that is the data big onyx data lab we
will have let's look at all the
different they will describe molecular
data so we have DNA mutation variants we
have expression analysis non-coding RNA
RNA editing events traction phone
different transcriptomes here to seek
advice or fatigue epigenetic regulation
we also have mass spec data like
metabolomics and proteomics and
lipidomics and all of this data and
speaks about biological events in two
interpreters biological events you have
statistical analysis of the data
integration of the data and rubbish and
that is really what we do as I landed
alright so what do you think who is the
usual a letter again what are some
barriers to the use of the like your dad
and how can you be more effective in the
analysis today okay so now what I want
to do is just me speaking a little bit
about t bio are discovered platform that
it's focused on delivering high speeds
and awesome and visualization tools so
that people can work with multi
Republic's data and integrate that data
and also learn from these and attention
so what is our vision well in the 1950s
the DNA double helix structure we
discovered and throughout the 1980s the
genetic code is craft and the first game
and sequencing technology Roosevelt
eventually by 2015 and 15 we see
proliferation of data and that becomes
widely available through our research
and avenging culture furthermore what we
see in that in the near future we'll see
more and more than anything in real life
I hope so what we see is our role that
we want to play his analysis integration
of data to provide diagnostics and
catification first of all for precision
diagnostics and eventually to support
personalized medical treatment / so why
is it so complex and so complex because
we have different networks which on
levels of data organ network cellular
networks molecular network solutions and
only thing look actually interact and
different ways and so genes and their
regulation that is more of the objects
data today that one of the organ
networks that is a clinical teacher
right out those are the data that
studied in a clinical setting and but we
see one more merging of those two types
of data set and obligated crossing over
into the clinical data mode ionic multi
onyx in the concept of many different
types of onyx dad genomics such as cell
growth for example or cell shape
genomics for example single nucleotide
creations sandy recipe quantum or prisms
epigenomics chronicling remodeling
for example transcriptomics I'll tell
Tyson Events repeat comics and
transposons proteomics mountains are
expressed in turn into proteins and
eventually metabolomics metagenomics
leaving other components like microbiome
the viral and so all of these data I
think play together they affect one just
one who they affect one another and to
understand the underlying biological
oddities we need to see all of those
data points together what are we working
how we are working on really a lot of
different areas much as personalized
medicine we have projects in biology a
drug design our mark discovery
epidemiology with many differences as an
example I want to give you a practical
projects where and if we look at page
four castrate-resistant prostate cancer
you can see the challenge of treatment
selection a combination with chemo
determining when your treatment like a
combination of different treatments and
a defining asian to match our global
tracks and this is kind of like provide
you a translation of research project of
integration different kind features of
data integrating that into the clinical
decision support for pharma bangles it's
insulting okay so as I mentioned we have
this platform this platform works right
now for research project and education I
actually coming out data and we've
tested it on a number of validation
projects in collaboration with various
researchers we've got some great
feedback is it consumed on the different
types of data sets that we've analyzed
and the tools that will you provide well
thank you for joining me today and
hearing about personalized medicine and
what time buyers like is doing in
personalized medicine I'm excited to
participate in the work that for team
does and in the next meeting we will
start going over some of the projects
that we've been working on and some
examples of how this data gets
integrated and generalize the platform
itself lies on the tools that we have as
well as some of the specific
collaborations and we would like to
discuss